foreign
let's go to Brittany in
Salt Lake City what's up Brittany
hey Doctor John how are you good what
are you doing
uh well I'm not on Instagram or Tick
Tock because I don't have an account so
I'm sorry I can't follow you on there
listen ridiculous number one number two
thank God you're probably the most
adjusted I should be calling you I
should be because you know how life
works that's good man so what's up
um well today I'm looking for ways to um
make friends and long-lasting
connections
um I have huge trust issues and when it
comes to creating relationships
okay how do I overcome that tell me more
so
I think what it comes down to is you
know when I was a child my dad was an
alcoholic and he would get angry and
um and he was verbally abusive and you
know if the fight was big enough he
would leave for hours maybe even days
and so you know being a child I'm
guessing that just you know has stuck
with me okay you know you're the big
part of my life a huge relationship that
I had and he would just up and leave and
so just I've always struggled with that
through you know grade school anytime I
had a friend and I started feeling like
you know they were kind of pulling away
I I would push them out of my life
before they could pull away okay
um because if I hurt if I just leave the
relationship then they don't have a
chance to hurt me yeah and so I feel
like I'm still doing it today and it's
not even just friends but it's you know
it can be family members or
um are you married
yes I am do you do this too too
yeah how come yeah so here's the and I
ask you how come
um one of the Cardinal questions to
never ask somebody in counseling is like
why why do you do that right
um or how come you did that here's uh
one we're not this isn't therapy like
I'm just some lame podcaster so that's
number one but the the bigger
overarching issue is
you've actually thought through this and
you've probably been a counseling before
you've done the work you know
and so at this point as an adult you're
choosing to continue this Behavior or it
may be so automated you're choosing to
not seek alternative actions and
thoughts that you know will make your
life
better
so I ask you why aren't you choosing
that
I think I'm just scared of what because
you've lost people
yeah of just creating the relationship
in general like I'll go to the gym and
I'll notice you know a girl comes up and
says hi and she seems to be interested
in you know being my friend and I will
get out of there as fast as possible
okay and I feel uncomfortable like it it
hurts almost
the suckiest part about your path
forward is the only way to Healing is
through this you can't go around it
anymore
um anxiety has got this bizarre
self-reinforcing mechanism that makes it
amazing
if you your body gets anxious about
something let's say there's like uh
basketball goals make you really anxious
really anxious and then you start to
walk near a park that's got a basketball
goal and your heart starts beating real
fast and like you said it starts burning
like your body's like hot like I gotta
get out of here and you run
and you think I can never go in that
park again it's got a basketball goal
your anxiety actually did its job it
kept you from what it had identified as
a threat as something scary something
that would hurt and kill you
and so it won
and so it actually reinforces itself it
gets stronger like Ah that's how we keep
her out of there
and the only way through it is in in the
nerd world it's exposure Theory like
you've you have to go slowly be
introduced to basketball goals until you
can walk into that situation
and your body doesn't respond and go to
war because it realizes that's safe
I tell you that to tell you when it
comes to people when it comes to
relationships the only way through where
you are is a choice
that I am not going to push somebody
away just because
I have a different attachment Style
just because when I'm used to when my
feelings were heard somebody left or if
I
um there was a fight I didn't think they
were coming back
and so now when you get in a fight with
your husband I don't think he's coming
back as your body's default mode it just
instantly goes there and so you go ahead
and accelerate the process and kick his
butt out
right yeah and you're gonna lose your
husband fair right yeah Fair
you're gonna go through life pretty
lonely Fair
yeah that I'm already feeling that okay
so what if I challenged you this way
is the way your body has chosen to cope
over the years is it working now as an
adult
it's not okay
would you be willing to do something
different
yes it will be very uncomfortable but
correct yes you are one million percent
right uh have you ever heard me say talk
about choosing your heart
um
I'm coming more and more to believe that
uh living a non-anxious life living a
life of more peace than not
is about choosing a a heart path
because here's the deal it's really hard
to be a hundred pounds overweight it's
hard on your knees it's hard on your
body right it's hard on your mental
health it's hard on your sleep it's hard
on every on your relationship it's hard
it's just hard
it's not good but I'm not I'm not
judging it's just hard
and it's really hard to lose 100 pounds
and it's really hard to keep off 100
pounds that's hard too
and so we often get get into a
um
an either or path which is I'm just
going to take the easy path which is I'm
just going to avoid people
I'm gonna take the easy path I'm not
gonna tell my husband what I actually
need I'm not going to tell my husband
that I'm hurting I'm not gonna tell my
husband that he's making me feel less
than I'm just gonna ride it out
or I'm just gonna ignore him I'm just
gonna kick him out
um and not maybe not kick him out of the
house but kick him out
um with silence or kick him out with
ignoring him or kick him out with I'm
just going to stay on social media and
scroll while he's doing whatever he's
doing
um we think that's the easy path
it's not it's killing us
it's killing us
and then the other path feels so hard
like I'm like I can't just like say my
needs out loud I can't just sit down and
look my husband and I say I need this
from you or I can't just tell that
person in the gym hey you wanna go get
coffee
because they might say no they might
look at you like whoa weirdo lady I was
just trying to be polite
that could super happen and that'd be
hard and weird or worse they could say
yes and now you gotta go get coffee with
a stranger and that can be insane
because they might be a Democrat or they
might be they might be like Trump 2024
and the rest of time like you don't know
you don't know it could be anything
it's not a matter of choosing hard or
choosing easy it's just choosing which
hard path you're going to take
and when I have come to understand that
I'm always going to take the hard path
that's going to lead me towards healing
and it's going to lead me towards peace
and that can only be found with
relationships and with integrity and
with authenticity and honesty I'm living
as
congruent to quote Rogers I'm living a
congruent life
and right now you're not right
right right and with my husband is like
um
as of late I don't I'm not sure why but
even when I go to into kiss him or hug
him he his body like naturally pulled
away and I'll mention it to him and he
I don't know if he's lying when he says
I didn't do anything or if he doesn't
notice that he does that and so that's
been a huge trigger for me lately
because you know I go in for a kiss
expecting this connection and he'll pull
away
and then he'll go in and kiss me
and so I think just lately you know with
him Elise that's that's where our
disconnect has been so I think where
else though because it's bigger than
that then if it's happening just just
there it's happening in other places
where else is it happening
um like with him
um well I mean with kind of with all the
intimacy really
it's you know I but so there's like
there's there's like
um
you're feeling like he's his impulse is
to back away from you right yes y'all
are having less sex than you would like
is that fair
oh yeah okay yeah a lot a lot less
um a lot less okay and it just seems
like he's just not interested at all
okay but back back out of the bedroom
where else is he not interested in you
is he making less eye contact is he
spending more time on his phone is he
working later
uh all of those things okay
so the the alarm system here
the the GPS is telling you here's the
address here's where we're going
but
that's not the like the the
destination's not the issue I mean this
is this is a a whole
it's just an alarm system for a greater
issue in your relationship
and having that conversation as you lean
in to kiss him and be like what's wrong
you don't like me am I not pretty
anymore like now everybody's now he's
got to defend himself you're on the
attack and then you're defending
yourself I'm not crazy right now you're
back and forth that's not the place to
have that conversation
it's to go to another location and to
sit with one another and say Hey look
something's changing our relationship
what's what's going on
I'm not crazy and have a couple of very
specific hey you've been on your phone
all the time in the last two months
we haven't had sex in the last 60 days
when's the last time you all you all
slept together
um probably two or three weeks ago okay
um
and I'm guessing it wasn't it was
perfunctory it wasn't uh yeah okay all
right that's what it's been like lately
okay and I've I've expressed
so
um he's actually going to the night
shift here soon and I've expressed to
him how you know we've been kind of
struggling in that area or at least I
have
um and my concerns with that and so back
at Christmas he
um he said he put a lot of thought into
this and he thought this would really
help me and so he actually got me a
vibrator yeah
and was like here you can do that
um and so that was really uncomfortable
for me and it made me even feel more
lonely because it was like no I want
that connection with you right did you
tell him that
yeah okay I and the conversation like
he's not feeling the same as me he's
happy whenever I talk to him he's happy
where he's at in his life
um
and I'm just like I'm I'm it's like I'm
you're looking for him here's how I know
he's not happy because his wife isn't
happy with him
his wife doesn't like him
yeah you don't like him and he is
increasingly and if you don't like
yourself often I don't like me and that
is reflected out onto other people don't
get close to me and the best way to keep
somebody from being close to you is for
you to not like them back
and I don't know how long that may have
been going on but there's
he has received the message
to the point that he has taken a left
turn and gone elsewhere
I don't know if he's seeing somebody
else or if he is
just settled into this General adult
male malaise how old is he
uh 30. yeah it's very con it's a strange
phenomenon that's happening Acro has
happened for the last 10 15 years it's
bananas
but just this generalized 30 to 45 year
old and older
nah
it's just kind of the way this is
and I'm not attracted to her I've put on
some weight she doesn't look like she
used to like she's just not into it I'm
just driving her crazy I'm just gonna
and it just it's just one degree and all
of a sudden the car is way on the other
side of the ocean
right
yeah and so there's something about
coming back saying not I want more of
this from you or
because that's like you need to be doing
these things
the conversation is begins with I miss
my husband
and I you're gone
that's where the conversation starts you
will eventually get to whether he needs
to go see a doctor and have his
testosterone checked or that he's
dealing with some mental health issues
he needs to work through or he is just
um
tired of taking criticism he's tired of
any number of relational things that
have made their way to the bedroom this
idea of sex drive Emily nagoski did a
remarkable job of of just setting that
whole thing on fire it's just a myth
it's not real
it's about ons and offs it's about gas
pedals and brakes and it's about
creating an environment where there's
enough gas pedals being pushed and
there's no breaks
and that can be environmentally the
house clean that can be I need it to
cold in here I need it warm in here I
need to help with the kids I need
whatever we need
but it's not about oh I just don't like
it you just it's it's a whole context
and some people are really into it once
a week and some people really into it
four times a week or eight times
whatever the thing is you negotiate
those relationally but this is the
intimacy here sounds very symptomatic
and I think the conversation starts with
I
I really miss you
and something's going on I need you to
be honest with me
because to stay I want us to stay not
only stay married but I want to
reconnect and so what is our path back
to each other it's owning reality we
have now found ourselves
six inches apart from each other in bed
but we're six thousand miles away from
each other
how do we find our way back how do we
begin dating again how do I we begin
flirting again how do we create desire
in this house how do we practice desire
how do we create an air of sexuality and
sensuality in our home we got to
practice coming back to each other it
can't just be I need this I need this
because the solution to I need this
is hey here's just a vibrator you can
take care of it whenever you want to
and now you can just leave me alone
because I'm not good at I don't know
what I'm doing clearly
um that's a totally different
proposition
and so
um
I would love before he goes off to his
new job that y'all go spend a couple
hours together
preferably in the morning
getting breakfast together in the
sunshine it's a little bit cold and
saying hey before we make this big life
transition I miss you
and I want you back in my life
and it's not just about sex it's about
texting it's about eye contact it's
about touch it's about hugs it's about
all these things and some of it may be
as simple as my wife and I years ago
implemented in the mornings when both of
us wake up we hug just hug
never occurred to one of us to do that
this but we hug this is a thing and we
both know that that starts a domino
that impacts both of our days
and I now it's weird when I'm on the
road like I just I expect that I need
that it's just a part of breathing for
me it's part of waking up and it's not
there when I'm on the road and so I
can't wait till I get home and I just
get that that Routine Morning hug he
just starts at it right whatever those
things are for you guys
we're just gonna have skin skin tonti
for three minutes in the morning we're
just gonna hold it Whatever It Is
you'll start figuring that out but that
will start with
I miss you
and I want you back
thanks for the call